dangerous flash flooding is slamming the
East Coast this morning as the region
cools down from a deadly record-breaking
heat wave the threat which started
Monday extends from Tennessee to Rhode
Island at the height of yesterday's
storm more than 325 thousand people were
without power in the mid-atlantic region
Don Dahler shows us just how the storm
rolled through intense storms pounded
the Northeast Monday as millions were
still reeling from days of relentless
heat powerful winds and heavy downpours
set up car alarms in Brooklyn and flash
flooding quickly submerged city streets
some New Yorkers were stranded while
others decided to brave nehi flooding
torrential rain poured into subway
stations and blocked highways during the
evening rush all lanes on the Long
Island Expressway were closed when this
woman took matters into her own hands
wading out of her car and using a
traffic cone to clear a clogged sewer
grate
golf-ball-sized hail fell in New Jersey
as intense winds downed trees and power
lines three branches are falling all
around me and then I get to this one
telephone pole and this wire I saw it
snap right off the Pope an 89 year old
man died in Maryland when a tree fell on
him in his driveway during a storm more
heavy rain is expected this morning
throughout the Northeast for CBS this
morning Don Dahler New York